they were called comfort women a term
used to describe women and girls forced
to work in brothels run by the japanese
military
it's estimated up to 200 000 girls and
women from asia were sexually enslaved
they endured rapes beatings even murder
those who survived often had to live
with the stigma
a significant number were from korea a
former colony of japan
and it's here in south korea that the
world's longest running protest
continues to take place
each wednesday around noon
survivors activists and ordinary
citizens have gathered in front of the
former japanese embassy in seoul to
demand an apology and compensation from
the japanese government
this year some survivors sent video
messages as covet 19 concerns prevented
them from attending in person
japan insists that it never forcibly
dragged us out of korea and never made
us suffer but i demand they stop lying
and be honest
there are only 13 of the women still
alive in south korea
grandmothers are passing away without
receiving a proper apology and
compensation let's fight until the
japanese government gives an official
apology and legal reparations are made
so that the lives and cries of the
grandmothers are not in vain
six years ago japan and south korea
reached an agreement
japan apologized and provided nearly
nine million dollars to a fund to help
survivors but that deal has largely
fallen through
survivors were critical of it saying it
prioritized money over a more sincere
apology from japan
and when president moon jae-in took
office he effectively abandoned the
agreement signed by his predecessor
calling it seriously flawed
relations between south korea and japan
took a further dive yet week after week
year after year
protesters remain undeterred in their
quest for justice
as the demonstrations continue into a
third decade
a new generation of activists have taken
up the fight
florence louis al jazeera